the military rescue workers and locals
spent hours picking through mud and
debris searching for signs of life
in this poor neighborhood in colombia's
dos corrales region
heavy rain continued through the night
loosening the soil on the mountain
by morning a large chunk had broke free
burying the homes below
it was a very loud bang at 6 30 in the
morning and it swept away all the houses
in front of it about six houses
including the people inside
it felt like the whole world was coming
down my brother was shouting get out get
out of the river it's overflowing and
when we got out the tragedy had already
happened people were shouting my brother
pulled a lady out who had already died
my father pulled out an elderly lady who
was our lifelong neighbor
families from dozens of homes have been
moved away from danger zones local
authorities say the nearby autumn river
is overflowing and the soil on the
mountain remains unstable
they also fear any more mudslides could
block the river and cause major flooding
first we're working on the rescue
secondly we are mitigating the risk
factor in the upper part of the
landslide which are the water flows and
the factors that generated the disaster
the emergency
the death toll is expected to rise as
many have been taken to hospital with
critical injuries
the problem of mudslides is common here
during the rainy season and has led to
major catastrophes in the past the
biggest in 2017 when 320 people were
killed in the southern puerto mayo
province
those most vulnerable often live in
poorly constructed wooden homes built on
mountains in valleys and along rivers
in dos quebradas it's those impoverished
communities who are left not only
displaced but dealing with the deaths of
family members
laura about manly al jazeera